welcome back okay so we have talked a
lot about linear system identification
using the eigen system realization
algorithm and the observer calman filter
identification so here we're gonna do
some quick MATLAB demos just to show how
this works on toy systems remember in
test sis this is just a discrete random
state space system with a hundred states
kind of a hundred hidden variables
dynamic variables in the eau de two
inputs and two outputs okay so I'm going
to load this let's run this good I'm
going to act like all I have is data
okay I don't have access to the model
ABCD I just have data so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna run this impulse of the
full system I'm gonna collect that data
in Y full that's the only data that I
have access to with er a all I have is
measurements of life all and then I'm
rerunning impulse without the output
just so it plots it to the screen and
you can see it and then there's some
funky stuff here I'm doing I'm permuting
this output cuz this output is not the
same shape I want it for my code so I'm
putting it into the right matrix format
and just so that you know there's this
ER am code that you'll have access to so
this is a code that I wrote you know a
long time ago based on ER a that
computes basically the reduced ABC and D
matrices from your data Y at rank R you
can read through this I also have an
okay ID code that I wrote I guess a
while ago given measurements of you and
and Y and some target rank R it'll build
that impulse response and put it into
this matrix H that you can then use for
er a okay so you have access to these
codes but remember we have a system
we're gonna collect data from that
system that's what we're gonna do here
and in this case this is what the data
looks like okay so I have two inputs and
two outputs and if I give an impulse an
input one I get this output and this
output and if I have an impulse and
input two
these are the two output responses so
again if I have a two input two output
system I get an array of impulse
responses I get two by two impulse
responses and this is literally the data
that I collect I have an experiment I
whack my actuator with a hammer I like I
crank up the control knob and I can
crank it back down and this is what I
measure this is all of my data for ER a
okay okay so computing er a from the
impulse response is pretty simple
I had to reshape my data into a
particular format I basically reshaped
it so that I guess I'll have to write
this up if I had reshaping your data is
pretty pretty interesting actually how
do i how do I want to say this let's say
I have Q inputs and P outputs and just I
guess we can assume it's two and two in
this case
so what I would end up doing is I get
one impulse response for each of these
inputs and each of those impulse
responses has P measurements so in our
case remember we had these kind of you
know in one in two out one out two and I
had these various you know impulse
responses just gonna do my best to draw
something stable okay
what I would have to do what this
reshaping is doing is at time step one I
take that measurement and I reshape that
into a little two by two matrix I call
that kind of my first block then at time
step two I take all four of those
measurements and I reshape them into a
block at time step three i reshape those
into a two by two block and another two
by two block and these are kind of those
matrices from before this is my D matrix
this is C B this is C a B this is C a
squared B I'm reshaping my four impulse
responses into this evolving two by two
matrix and that's kind of an important
step that you have to do in actually BPO
D or in ER a okay ID is really figuring
out how
how to manipulate your data into the
right structure to do this analysis once
you do that honestly I probably spent 30
minutes or an hour just figuring out the
right way to write this one line of code
but once you had that settled down now
what you do is you just run the ER a
code it's that simple I'm making this
MCO just tells me how big I should make
my Henkel matrix it's literally just how
much data I have minus 1/2 because it's
you know a symmetric matrix so I can
only use my matrix can only be half as
big as the length of this time series
and it's that simple all I do is run
this ER a code and I get an ABC and D
matrix that I can build into a system so
I have my er a system it's one line of
code you have my ER a code you can run
that one line okay you collect data you
put it in the right form
you run array you have it now I could
just plot the response and show you but
I also want to show you what if you
didn't have an impulse response what if
it was hard to get this data from an
experiment and instead maybe some
collaborator emailed you like what the
output response was to some random input
okay so if someone just emails you a
dataset and it's randomly forced to you
and the output response to that randomly
forced you you'd have to run it through
this second line of code this okay ID
code and this would give you a series of
these matrices that's H is basically
these matrices in a certain order okay D
then CBC ABC a squared B that's what's
in H okay then I basically just plug H
directly into ER a and I get my matrix
back okay so I hope this is clear if you
can get impulse response data you can
just do er a in one shot if you have
randomly forced input data you have to
first kind of estimate the impulse
response with okay ID then run it
through ER a but in both cases it's only
a few lines of MATLAB code once you have
these functions okay pretty simple let
me make sure I actually have run
everything this is important okay I'm
gonna run this good we have our data I'm
gonna run the ER a model
I've generated in the Aryan model I'm
going to here I actually have to
manufacture this random and put output
data but in the real world you'd collect
this from your experiments warning
simulation starts whatever okay and I do
it okay I D good now we're ready to plot
everything so this is where it gets kind
of cool ah perfect so this is the same
system we actually looked at with
balance truncation and balance PID and
these are the same impulse responses
same model order R equals 10 the
original system actually had a hundred
states and what you can see is that the
full model in blue is very well
approximated with a ten mode ER a model
and it's also pretty well approximated
with this ER a-okay ID model so
basically all of these cases work really
really well and in this case it's really
interesting I didn't have access to that
model all I had was data and I can fit a
low order state space model that very
accurately reproduces the system
response that I can then use for control
so system idea in the context of control
you really care about what's happening
you know how do i maximally capture what
happens given an input on my outputs and
that's what we're seeing here is given
an impulse and the inputs this is the
output response and our low order model
our ten mode model does a great job of
capturing these system dynamics purely
data-driven based on some deep and
foundational linear algebra Hankel
matrices henkle singular value reduction
balanced graeme ins but in practice very
simple to run these are one or two lines
of MATLAB code once you have your data
okay so please try this out download
some data generate your own data see
when it breaks down try it on nonlinear
systems this is a great tool but you'll
only understand it if you actually start
applying it and and trying it out okay
thank you very much